Good evening everyone. This is Congressman Nick Langworthy and I want to thank you for
joining me tonight and welcome to this month's telephone town hall meeting. If you've joined
us before, you know this is part of a monthly series. We do this each and every month where
I have the opportunity to update you on what's happening in Washington and what I'm working
on and get your feedback at the same time. That's what this is about. It's two-way dialogue.
So I can hear from you about the issues that you care about and answer your questions.
If this is your first time joining us for one of the telephone town hall meetings, welcome.
It's great to have you. At any point during the call, if you want to join the line to
ask a question, press star three on your phone. Again, star three on your phone. We're going
to get to as many questions as we can tonight. For those of you that have joined before,
you know that while we have people that help facilitate the caller's question, we do not
screen topics of the phone calls. I talk to plenty of people that disagree with my positions.
We have people from every political persuasion on these calls as a governmental function.
So we do not screen this in the people that call in to this by party affiliation. But,
you know, there's nine counties in this district and I'm happy to take any tough questions
or criticisms. In fact, I welcome the opportunity to share with you my thoughts on anything and
have a productive dialogue, even if at the end we don't agree. Our only requirement
is that you're respectful so that the thousands and thousands of people that are on this call
can benefit from a robust discussion as well. So again, that's star three to ask a question.
We are back in session in Washington right now after a very productive time in the district
in August. And I really value the time in the district because it allows me to be on
the ground meeting with everyday taxpayers, our business owners, our not-for-profit leaders,
hospitals, law enforcement, first responders, local government officials, and all of the
other organizations affected by our federal laws, our regulations and funding. You know,
this time is essential to hear what's going on, what people need help with, and that's
how a lot of problems are solved, either through our office's case work, our advocacy, or even
ideas for bills or legislation. Seeing a business or a public institution firsthand and being
on the ground, having in-depth conversations where we can ask them questions in real time
is invaluable to me as your representative. And I was honored to have the chance to travel
across our district that spreads from southern Niagara County, through Erie, down to Chautauqua,
and all the way across the southern tier to almost Binghamton. It's a huge district, as
many of you know. And while, you know, we have issues that unite us, every community
has unique attributes and needs. And some of the events have become annual visits, like
spending time, you know, with our seniors. And I think there was probably 700 seniors at
the Allegheny County Senior Picnic, and it's in Clairville 76ers, or talking to some of
our district's incredible farmers and growers at the County Fairs in the Eden Corn Festival.
But I also had the chance to tour so many great businesses, like New Corps, Volcraft,
and Elmira, and Dawson Metal, and Jamestown, and meet with employees and management, along
with, you know, meeting with many labor organizations, whose workers power those businesses. So if
you're just showing the call, please press star 3 to get in the queue. It was also proud
to meet with so many other important organizations, like the Dubuis Boys and Girls Club, and the
Stable Home Foundation, and Bemis Point, that offer equine-assisted therapy for our veterans
and foster children and children with disabilities. You know, we went to many volunteer fire
departments and law enforcement organizations where we discussed how we can help them obtain
the equipment to keep our volunteer firefighters safe. And that's important that we fight for
those federal resources. That's just a little snapshot of what we did over the last month.
But I also wanted to share it with you because it all feeds into another highlight of what
we did in the month of August, which was the America 250 Community Heroes Award ceremonies
I held across the district. And I launched that award in honor of our nation's 250th birthday
because I've always believed it's the everyday citizens quietly serving who are the backbone
of this great country. These were not folks looking for recognition, but they made incredible
contributions in their community every day, and they embodied the character and the values
of integrity and patriotism and belief in something greater than themselves that truly
embodies the American spirit. And they were very uplifting ceremonies, and we honored
250 people across the district. They were excellent events, and I probably had 1,500
people there across all the events. But, you know, people really stepped up and participated
in that, and I wanted to say thank you for everyone that nominated a candidate for those
awards. We were able to honor so many healthcare workers and law enforcement officers, teachers
and coaches and firefighters and veterans, and just regular everyday citizens who stepped
up and answered the call to help when they were needed. So thank you so much. You know,
one of the last thing before we get into the questions I want to talk about, you know,
making sure that we haven't hit the table in important public policy discussions. And
one of those is for the Lake Erie grape growers. And, you know, we had a company, Refresco,
that, you know, had a very large supply of our region's concrete grapes that were under
contract to that entity to make use. And they abruptly canceled that contract while the growing
season was already underway. And it was a very unfortunate, you know, poor corporate
behavior. I guess it's the best way I can call it. It's really inconsiderate because
the growers had so much invested in this year's crop. And we've been working with these growers
now for months. And I was very glad to see the announcement last week. The USDA came in and
purchased $20 million worth of grape juice concentrate to help stabilize the markets for our grape
Lake Erie grape growers. And something like this is the difference between a multi-generational
farm being able to keep the doors open or, you know, being forced to sell. And this is just a
small step in, you know, the ultimate process. We've got to find new markets for these products
and expand the use of them across the entire, you know, American diet. But it was a great example
of someone bringing us a problem and us getting a solution for it. So it's an honor of a lifetime
to fight every day in Washington for this district. And certainly could go on and on for
hours. But I want to get into your questions. So again, press star three on your phone. And we
are going to get to our first caller. And we're going to go to Jeremy.
Hello, Jeremy. Hi, how are you? I'm doing very well. Where are you calling from tonight, Jeremy?
Alfred Station, New York. Oh, okay. Great to have you with us. What's on your mind?
Well, I'm an owner, operator, truck driver. And we do regional work up here. And I see they're
doing great work on getting some of the illegals out, which is, you know, helping us as far as rates
and stuff like that go. But we also have the problem with cabotage where we have a lot of Canadian
truck drivers that come down out of Canada, work in the US, bring their loads back to Rochester,
Buffalo, which they're not supposed to do. And I'm wondering if there's anything going on with that.
Well, I haven't had the discussion about Canadian truckers taking American work,
but it's one that, you know, that's, that's what's valuable about these exchanges because it gives
us ideas and things to discuss with the different federal agencies. Is this, so usually this is
a limited problem. So the Canadians are coming into the US setting up shop and just going from
one American destination to another American destination. Are they just taking the work back
to Canada? Yeah, from one American destination. They're allowed to take the work back to Canada,
but they're doing from one American destination to the next American destination. And effectively,
that's, you know, that's stealing. That's stealing from American jobs. And, you know, now we're
competing with Canadian drivers also. Well, it would strike me that they would need it. Come back
up to Rochester and work in work in the United States for the United States. Yeah, they could
cross-border truck like I'm a cross-border trucker also. I could take the US to Canada, but, you know,
we can't haul Canada to Canada if I get something I have to haul back into the US, which for these
guys, there's not a lot of product going back up with the Canada. So they, they get a lot of stuff
going into the Wegmans tops, you know, local businesses up in, in Rochester, Buffalo,
Dunkirk come back delivered her stuff, bounce empty back across the border. And that's effectively
stealing from us. I mean, we're, you know, why should we have to compete with them? And it seems
like a third violation of the law. Jeremy, we're going to take down your number and we're going
to dig into this a little more and be back in touch with you. I could be because this is the
first I'm hearing about this being an issue, but I definitely want to get more educated on it and
see if there's anything, you know, we can do to, to put an end to it because, you know,
American truck driver, I mean, there's a law there and it doesn't get in force.
Well, I really appreciate you hearing it with us. And we low the state DOT should have a good
arm on that, but I can see where it would be hard to track. But I absolutely, but, you know,
it could be done. So do the, do the tractor trailers have American tags or Canadian tags?
Canadian tags. We were next to them. We loaded all of the shippers right next to them. And the
brokers know this and, you know, the companies that are shipping it know it. It just, you know,
it's one of them things that just gets done. Nobody pays attention to it.
Well, thank you for bringing it to my attention, Jeremy. And we'll be back in touch with you.
All right. And next, we will be going to Lawrence.
Do we have you alone? Hi, Lauren. How are you? Hi, I'm calling from Orchard Park, New York.
Oh, thanks for being with us tonight. What's on your mind? I would like to know what your opinion
is of our current relationship with Canada, the renaming of Lake Ontario.
And then I'd like to know what you think your constituents think about this as you represent us
in Congress. I am kind of sickened to how this is all falling apart because, you know, I felt
like we were in a good place. It looked like the negotiations were moving along. And that's
certainly how we were briefed. I mean, the president made an announcement and then everything abruptly
ended. And, you know, I think there, we need to work together with our neighbor. I mean,
it's a country that, you know, people in our community travel too often, you know, could have
loved ones in. It's a neighbor like Pennsylvania is a neighbor. Oh, yes, it's a foreign country,
but it's a trusted neighbor. And historically, we've had each other's back. Now, we could have
a disagreement on the numbers. But I think that both sides need to tone down the rhetoric. You
know, the, you know, Ontario is a name that's been around for hundreds of years. People will
still be referring to the lake as Lake Ontario. Ontario has strong native traditions. And, you know,
I heard President J.C. Seneca loud and clear, you know, with his criticism of the executive
order renaming the lake. So, you know, I don't think that it's necessary, just like I don't think
it's necessary for the premier of Ontario, Doug Ford to threaten that he's going to cut the power
off to New York. And this brinksmanship should come to an end. They should sharpen the pencils,
sit down, figure out what divides us on a deal. And let's get a new strong bilateral trade deal.
You know, I'm on Interparliamentary Council. I work very closely with members of parliament.
They're very frequent visitors to my office. And, you know, I think, you know, largely our
countries have strong admiration for each other. And, you know, we certainly welcome a lot of Canadians
into Western New York and, you know, Canada, you know, welcomes us with open arms. I mean,
you see it at our sporting event, you see it, you know, throughout our Western New York culture.
So, you know, that's my opinion on the issue. I would like this to finish. I would like us to
get serious about a deal. I think, you know, the Canadian government desperately needs a deal.
You know, they, unfortunately, have some provincial elections. And I do think that,
you know, Canadian officials have experienced some popularity by fighting against the president
and, you know, understandable. I mean, I've been very public in my disagreement with the
president about statehood for Canada. I don't, you know, that's I think that's ludicrous. They're
strong, proud, independent country. And I respect that. And I think we need to treat them as that.
But, you know, they have gotten more popular with their own constituents because they fought back.
Against Trump on a trade deal. And I know they have some provincial elections coming up in
October. And I think we're seeing a lot of friction and noise because of that. But hopefully,
you know, at the end and sometime in the not so distant future, we can have a strong bilateral
deal. I think they're very close. I think it's just a matter of a few sticking points that
got everyone to get up from the table. So, does that answer your question?
It does. And I, if I may say this, I look forward to your strong and persistent influence on this
subject. It's important to our economy, important to our relationships. And I think those that are
dictating that policy need to hear from you because you represent a lot of people that are
affected daily by that interaction. Yeah. I mean, I think everybody's got to really,
you don't negotiate trade deals through the media. You do this in a room and you figure out,
you pour over the numbers and you get something done. I mean, we have defended each other as
countries. We've aided each other. There should not be these hostilities. And it's not healthy.
And, you know, obviously, I'm very close to it because my district is a border, you know, a border
Canada. You know, some people in the country don't have the same feelings because Canada is
a far off land to them if you represent somewhere in the deep south. But I have great admiration
for the Canadian people. So, thank you. Go get them. Thank you so much. Take them up.
Thank you, Lawrence, for being with us. We're going to talk to James.
Hi, James. Thank you for taking my call. My pleasure. Where are you calling from tonight?
I'm calling from Angola, New York. Okay. Actually, I work for a company that's been here for 40 or
50 years from actually from Denmark. We make cutting and grinding wheels. We've been here for
approximately 50 or 60 years. Western New York has been very, very good. Up until the last
15 or 20 years, I mean, things are getting harder and harder and harder to do business.
We're a small company of, you know, 50 to 90 employees. And it's getting harder and harder
to do business in Western New York. And what will you do to help keep these smaller industrial
companies that keep our small little towns like Angola going? I mean, we've lost major
major employees in our area, you know, throughout the past 40, 50 years. And it's killing the area.
And what will you do to help us? Well, what I've done is I've put the most advantageous tax
code for businesses to grow forward. And, you know, we voted on that last year and made that
the law and made that tax code permanent so businesses can grow and expand and expense their
investments and their reinvestments and their businesses and, you know, get that payoff right
away. And that is, that is a big step. Unfortunately, when we create policy, it's for all 50 states
and you're competing against neighboring states that have different business climates. And,
unfortunately, for New York, our business climate isn't what it needs to be. We've had
an increase in our utility bills because, you know, the Governor's Public Service Commission
has increased rates twice. You know, we've got too many regulations on the books and they've
driven a lot of people out of our area. You know, I, I'm still surprised despite all of that going
against us, how many places that I visit and employers that are searching to find people for
the jobs that they have, which I never thought that that would be the case. And my lifetime,
that there would be more jobs open than there would be people willing to do those effectively.
But, you know, I don't know if that's something that your businesses face, the
difficulty getting workers or not. But it is something that a lot of employers in our region
are facing and we need to continue that pipeline and do some more investment in workforce training.
And I'm working on getting some federal funds, you know, for our different educational institutions
so that they have those monies to train the workers. But we also need Albany to wake up
and understand that you just can't tax people into submission. You're chasing too much of our
human capital out of this state, a lot of our brain power, and a lot of investments. And other
states are coming in and, you know, enticing businesses to move. I hope your company doesn't
move because I truly appreciate businesses that, you know, continue to employ people here in our
region. But, you know, we would always, you know, be there to work, you know, on any sort of grants
or partnerships, you know, with workforce investment that, you know, we could possibly help you with.
Our company, our company had a devastating fire on the 4th of July. I want to say 35 years
ago burned to the ground and was totally rebuilt. And then during a blizzard, 10 or 11 years ago,
the entire warehouse collapsed and it was rebuilt a second time. And we're having trouble getting
qualified employees, getting people to work, getting, I mean, the gas bills, the electric
bills, everything has went up and up and up and up. And I'm not an owner. I'm a supervisor
there at this company and I've been there for a long, long time. And the owner has put his money
and invested into Western New York over and over and over. And he's one of the very few in our area
that that in Western New York and Angola flex a bit USA. I mean, and I hope you come to visit us,
but I would really like to come visit. And we'll give you a call offline and get the specifics.
And I would love to come see it. I'd love for you to come out and see us and tell us how you can
help us. I mean, and great. We're for you 100%. Well, it's great talking to you, James. Thank you
so much for being with us tonight. Next, we're going to talk to Thomas.
Is there more than one town? Hello. Hello. How are you, sir? Where are you calling from tonight?
I'm calling from Pendleton, New York. I know that town pretty well.
Thanks. Thanks so much for being with us. What's on your mind tonight? Well, I got a couple things.
One of them is about the seniors. They are the president and the vice president just yesterday
when he was up in Michigan, touted the no tax on social security. And that's totally wrong,
because the fact is there's a tax break, but unlike no tax on tips and no tax on overtime,
in order to take advantage of this
no tax on social security, you got to live an entire year. You don't see it during a year.
You got to live a year and then collect it when you file your taxes and wait for your return.
The seniors need to help right away. They don't need to wait a year for that.
It was written as a tax credit. It's a seniors tax credit.
The net effect is that 82% of seniors have no tax on their social security.
So it's only the truly upper earning seniors that still would have their social security subject
attacks those that phase out of the tax credit because of their upper incomes.
But it is indeed a tax credit. It's not in the withholding based on the taxes paid on your other
incomes. Yeah, but you're missing the point. Everybody else sees their big beautiful bill
on no tax on overtime, no tax on tips. They see it immediately. The seniors have to wait a year.
Now I'm 76 years old. How many more years have I got to have to wait when I find my
budget? If you're paying, can I just ask you this question? So you currently employed?
76 years old. I understand. But if you have a taxable income,
that's beyond your social security earnings is when most people have the taxes taken out of
their social security. So you don't have any other earned income or? No, I have
I just have retirement and and that's you have your pension and with that it puts you up in an
upper or a bracket that would require you to pay taxes. Is that correct? Okay. Yeah, I mean,
this was you know, this was a complicated bill to write in order to get as many seniors to qualify
for it because every senior situation is different. Some just get their social security. Some have
a pension on top of it. Some seniors still work. So in order to get the senior's checks
credit to apply, it became a tax credit rather than within the withholding. So I do, you know,
it being as complicated as it was to make sure that it applied to everyone within
those earnings brackets. This is the way that it was put together at that point.
Well, I definitely understand what you're saying. I definitely understand what you're saying,
sir, but it's it does. The net effect is that 82% of our seniors don't owe any taxes at the end
of the year on their social security income. Yeah, but here again, you don't see it every
month when you get your check, your check. I understand that you would get a you would get a
refund, which you wouldn't have got before we wrote. Yeah, if you die 11 years into the year,
you know, you pay your taxes. What good is it to you?
I mean, that would be unfortunate. I don't want anyone to die, but but had we not passed this law,
there would be no rebate or refund at the end of the year. So I definitely understand, you know,
it would be better to have it delivered monthly within the check. But given the diversity of how
social security recipients receive their income, this was, you know, the technical way we were able
to deliver that. Well, and then the small part is the president and the vice president and your
party shouldn't be coming out and saying there's no tax on social security because there is. And you
got there's a $6,000 tax credit per senior citizen tax married company, $12,000. It's a tax credit.
So it's a net effect at the end of the year is that you're you're you have for a married couple,
it'd be $12,000, you know, back in your pocket. Well, didn't it square it up? Why didn't why
wasn't there just a tax credit for tips? Why wasn't there just a tax credit for overtime?
Well, I'll keep it all equal. I mean, those are based on the W2s of which our seniors do not have.
So that's this was a trickier part of the bill to write.
Just so they couldn't go out of their way to do the right thing for the seniors they had to put
all that's that's not it at all, sir. I mean, just the at the end of the day, I wish that it was
delivered monthly, but that you know, unfortunately, if you have a tax obligation, this is canceling
the tax obligation. But you don't have, you know, the regular earned income that, you know,
we're withholding on a payroll service would handle it, definitely.
Well, we're just we're just be at that or sir. The other point I had was, you know, the president's
coming out would talk about tax break for for movie producers and stuff like that. Is that is that
true? I mean, he said something about it. I don't know if he put out any specifics. This is a tax
credit that used to be there in times gone by. I think it expired in 2025. I have not looked into
it at all. But you know, a lot of filmmaking in this country has moved to Canada. I I presume
that the president brought it up because a lot of US content is actually filmed in Canada because
they offer tax breaks. So my guess is this is a backdoor way for he's working on those negotiations
with Canada. He's trying to store the tax credit that once existed. I don't I don't know enough about
it yet to have an opinion. Well, well, maybe you want to think about this with your opinion.
My opinion is on this. These people are making movies. They got some money or they're talking
to people that have the money to give them to make the movies. Instead of looking at a tax
break for people are making movies, why not a tax break for mom and pop restaurants in storage?
That would make. I mean, people put their life savings into a restaurant or a store. I don't
disagree with it. Live or die. They're you know, they're risking everything. So why not why not think
of those little guys to put in your opinion with the president instead of the people with the money
or the means to get the money? I think that's a very valid point. And I appreciate
you being on the line with us here today. And you know, I again, I I don't think you know,
movie tax credit should be a priority right now. So I appreciate you being with us here tonight,
Thomas. Next, we are going to go to Ann.
Hello, Ann. Yeah. Hello. How are you? I'm doing very well. Thanks for being with us tonight.
Great. Thank you for taking my call. Yes. Well, I I just wanted clarification. I believe
but I must might have missed a news cycle that the there was legislation passed on the
not banning insider trading for members of Congress. We passed the House a bill that would stop
members of Congress from buying stock or selling without notice. Okay. And did that go through?
It went through the House. It has not passed the Senate. We have we have about 500 bills
sitting over the Senate now. Yeah. Okay. So my question and concern is that I'm very concerned
about the president doing a lot of the trading. You know, you get the $1,000, you know, $100,000
a month heads up on what you might call it through social so that he can he can make,
you know, sell his bids and things like that. And you know, there seems to be a lot of stuff
that just doesn't sit right with me. And I just wonder how you feel about it and what can be done
to curtail that insider trading from the higher than Congress level?
Well, I think, you know, this this particular piece of legislation affected Congress. You know,
the inspiration of it is that there was a lot of members like literally day trading. And, you know,
people go through a classified briefing, get a piece of information, run off with it. You know,
the president certainly is trading stocks. I mean, I had a piece of legislation that,
you know, would have created a need for all executive branch employees to
give, you know, full transparency and ethics disclosures. But, you know, I think, you know,
anyone make it because it's not just, you know, the top decision maker. I'm concerned that there's
self-dealing that goes on. You know, you look at, think about the Pentagon and how many people
make procurement decisions, you know, at seven figure in up levels or eight figure in up levels.
And they have the ability to go out and purchase those stocks. And, you know, that's that's all
done. I think there needs to be full transparency on everyone. I mean, if we wanted to, you know,
or it could ever pass muster to, you know, ban anyone in the federal government from,
you know, purchasing stock and day trading. You should, you know, it's a privilege to serve.
You know, the law certainly doesn't prohibit anyone from doing it now, but perhaps it should
for everyone at the table. Yeah, it concerns me because it seems like the president should be the
one who kind of leads in that area. And it just seems like he's doing a lot. You know, his sons
have had deals with defense companies and then all of a sudden they're given contracts and,
you know, Bloomberg had out that 3,700 trucks for stock trades were made,
yielding billions of dollars in profits for the Trump family. And I just feel like there's nobody
stopping any of the stuff that's going on at the very top, you know, from cutting down, you know,
cherry trees and, you know, the demolition of the East Wing and going to war without a war
resolution. It just feels like there's a whole lot of, whoa, you know, does anybody have a break
pedal anywhere in Congress? And it just concerns me that every day you wake up and you go, oh my God,
who are we at war with now? Who are we bombing now? Who have we abducted now? What oil have we
taken? It's like the Wild Wild West in Washington right now, and it's very concerning to me. And I
wonder what can be done to kind of put the reins in the pump the brakes a little bit here?
Well, I believe that if you research, you'd find that any major conflict has generally started
with hostilities probably minus the Iraq war without an authorization of force. And, you know,
the president has been in it directly consulted the gang of 80 followed every bit of the notifications
when the hostilities started. So I don't, I don't believe that you have wars happening
without the proper notification. Now, you know, we haven't done a full blown war declaration in
many, many, many years, you just get the authorizations of force. I want to rant and I don't want to
have declarations. I want this to be ended. And my hope is that through the economic sanctions,
that they will finally knuckle under, you know, agree to never have a nuclear weapon,
and we can get done with these hostilities. Because, you know, this is, this is not something
that I want to be a year's long quagmire. And I don't want any of our, you know, ground troops
to have to go there. And, you know, certainly haven't seen the cause for that yet. So that's
my piece there. In terms of the stock trading, I mean, I know what I've done. I have chosen not to
engage in any stock trading since I ran for Congress. I don't own individual stocks. I don't
trade individual stocks. And I believe that should be the policy for the entire, for the entire
government, for that matter. Okay. Please don't let them cut down any cherry trees.
Well, I haven't dug into the cherry trees, but, you know, I know that there's, there's usually
something new that's been in the news that people exercised about. But thank you for being with us.
Yeah. Okay. Thank you.
Okay. Next, we're going to go to Todd.
Hi, Todd. Hey, how's it going, sir? I'm doing very well. Where are you calling from tonight?
For Tonya? Okay. Well, thanks for being with us. What's in your mind?
So, Mark, what are you calling? Plarsec?
Pollen cars? And so, yes, canceled DHS.
He canceled the, so there was going to be a large department of Homeland Security job fair
that was going to be at the Buffalo Convention Center and about five days out, six days out,
the county executive canceled that. So, they started it today. They actually moved it over to
the Coast Guard Station where they had enough space to do most of it.
So, it did just ridiculous what went on there. Well, I work for DHS. So, that's my question.
What can we do, you know, I drive to Buffalo for DHS. So, do I feel insecure going to Buffalo
working for DHS? I mean, are you asking me if you feel secure?
Yeah. I mean, if they don't want to support us, let me just state my opinion very clearly.
This was a ridiculous action. You know, they signed the contracts, they took the deposits,
they did the money, and they had clauses in there. And I do believe there were somewhat
of a setup so that the county executive could make a political statement and, you know, have
street credibility among his cheerleaders that he canceled a ICE job fair. Now, ICE was going
to have hiring there, but so was TSA. So, were every other DHS entity that, you know, very well
as an employee there, that, you know, I worked with DHS to try to find alternative locations,
but it was, you know, they had already had all the plane reservations, the accommodation set up.
It was, they couldn't move it out of, you know, the downtown corridor. I mean, they had to ask
for 30,000 square feet to set up because this is the kind of job fair that someone could go in,
have the screenings done, and walk out with a good paying job. And Mark Polenkars just had no problem
canceling that. And no, I agree. Incredible people that serve DHS. They defend our country.
They defend our homeland. I appreciate you and all your fellow employees and what you do.
So, we worked very hard through the weekend trying to find alternative location. They landed on the
idea, the best place to have it was the Coast Guard building. And it's going on right now.
There were 1,400 people registered to go potentially get a job. And I just, I'm just a
guest that any public official would take the opportunity away from a person in our region
that wanted to go inquire about a job that was correct.
And, but look at this way, if you take out the federal government jobs from Buffalo,
how would that hurt? It hurt really badly. Exactly. And I have one more question.
Yes, sir. So, why are they against telework? Well, I think that the telework,
a lot of the executive orders on telework would go back to the way telework was prior to the pandemic.
I mean, what I think we've seen across a lot of entities is some places, some industries,
telework can work, but we had agency buildings full of people here in Washington that hadn't
been to work in five years. So, the pandemic was long done with and people still weren't coming
into the office. And that was one of the big issues to limit telework to necessary components
and the policies that existed before the pandemic. There was just so much
COVID era policy that was hanging over, even though the emergency was ancient history.
And that's why a lot of the telework has been eliminated. You know, we have these offices,
we have places. I know, I know the city of Buffalo itself has suffered greatly from,
you know, people not, you know, they've gotten very comfortable in telework and a lot of
businesses haven't brought their employees back into the office. And it's hurt the city.
It's hurt a lot of the restaurants and the facilities and not that they should be the only
consideration. But, you know, I do think that there was a lot of people who wanted to see us
get back to, you know, normal operating procedures. And we were no longer in an emergency.
I'm sorry, but I disagree because I was teleworking before the pandemic. And now we're not
loved telework anymore. You're not allowed at all. Gotcha. No, exactly. And that went
against our union contract. And what is the union come back with?
The union bought it and CBP, even in the arbitration, they said, yes, we agree,
telework should be allowed. But they did not do that. Yes, they did.
The that's our union said, no, so they went against our union.
Okay. I know that most of the things that I dealt with on the oversight committee were
trying to restore the telework policies of the federal government back to the telework policies
of 2019. So, you know, happy to. Why would they take that away from the union, though,
if it was in the contract? I do not know the answer to that question,
but happy to, you know, dig into it offline a little more with you if we could take down
your number and give you a call. Absolutely. Oh, please. Let's do that. All right.
Yes. And just for the gentleman that was talking about the truck drivers coming over from Canada,
you can file certain things because if it's taken the way jobs from the American people,
you can file something against that. Okay. We will we will be digging into that one as well.
I've got a lot of homework from this call, for sure. But I appreciate you being with us,
Todd, and we'll be back in touch with you. Thank you. Next, we're going to talk to Amy.
Hello. Hi. Hi, Amy. How are you? Good. How are you? I'm doing very well.
I am in Allegheny County. Okay. Thanks for being with us. And we have
had several large businesses close in our community over the last few years.
And I'm just wondering, do you have any ideas of how to bring business back to our location?
Because the last statistics I've looked at, we are the most
wealthier per capita in the entire state because we just don't have jobs in our area.
No, it is it's a it's a problem in Allegheny County. And, you know, the loss of the cheese
plant to Ken Rogers County was not beneficial for Allegheny County's bottom line or a lot of
those workers. And dress around as well. Dress around. Yep. And I will say that I toured the
dress around facility during the August recess, which is now under Chile and they're hiring.
They're looking to ramp up in a big way. If anyone's a welder, they're looking for 90 more
welders this year alone. They're doing some big pictures there. I have not heard that. They're
taking over that. They're fully operational in the dress around facility at this point.
In Wellsville? Not the Wellsville plant, the one in Oleia.
Okay. I'm specifically in Wellsville. Specifically in Wellsville. Yeah. So the
with the one in Oleia. Yeah. But the one that most recently closed was the one in Oleia.
I'm more concerned about Wellsville because I've been with Allegheny County.
Right. And but, you know, I work with the county elected officials. They have identified
a few opportunities to try to bring some workforce development issues and some, you know,
shovel ready sites to the table to hopefully attract some employers. We're working to get some
resources to get some public water drawn into particularly the gateway area. We got to create
the most advantageous place for a shovel ready site so they can, you know, create the jobs in the
area. And hopefully we can get some spinoff. I mean, the greatest loss that the area had was
losing the opportunity to, you know, harness the natural gas that's in Allegheny County,
which would have created thousands and thousands of jobs. Right. As well as Walmart,
which the older generation denied because they didn't want to lose the boutique sensation of
Wellsville, but we need jobs. We need money for these people in this area.
It's, you know, we have to have- Even if it's minimum wage.
We do have to have more jobs there. And, you know, there are some manufacturers and, you know,
we need to, you know, keep helping them grow. But we need to attract more. And, you know,
there's some of the things that we're trying to do with showing places and showcasing the fact
that Allegheny County is right on I-86. There is available land that, you know,
there's a great workforce in the general area that, you know, would come to those jobs. It's
the most we could do. But we're trying to work as much with the county government as possible
to try to do some things to attract businesses, for sure.
I hope so, because we're dying down here.
It's, you know, the unfortunate reality is that a lot of people are, you know, our communities
are shrinking. And we're losing a lot of popularity to other parts.
I get it. But the reason we're losing it is taxes of New York state in general.
People are leaving New York. And it's not even just people. It's just the companies are leaving.
And that obviously is leading to less jobs. So, yeah, we all have to move out of New York
because there's nothing left and the taxes are too high.
It's not fair, but it's a reality that's been thrust on us. And, you know, I can't get
overtly political on this call. Right. I get it. I get a lot of
engineering on this call because this is a governmental call. But, you know, people,
you know, have choices to make this year. Sure. Absolutely.
Well, thank you very much for being with us, Amy. And, you know, we'll keep working for Allegheny
County. Absolutely. Thank you. Thank you. Next, we're going to talk to Robert.
Hi, Robert. Hello. How are you? Where are you calling from tonight?
I'm, I'm calling from town maker. Oh, okay. Great to have you with us. What's on your mind?
First off, I just want to tell you the way that I was involved in this. It is amazing.
You're given a voice to people that normally don't have a voice. And I just wanted to
congratulate you on that. I think it's amazing. Well, thank you very much for saying that.
And my question is, I would like to know your stance on what I believe is a violation of our
constitutional Second Amendment right to bear arms in this state.
Which one of New York's many? There you go. There you go. Exactly it. You know, I'm a white person.
And I know that it doesn't really matter, but I live on Indian reservation. Okay. If you're
a Native American, you can own anything you want. You can own any kind of gun you want because of
their tribal sovereignty. Yeah. Which it should be our right as an American citizen to own any
gun we want. And to me, I feel like this state is just taking it away from, they think they're trying
to take them away from the bad people. But you ain't never going to take them away from those
people. You know, those people are going to do it whether you say yes or no. Criminals are
willing to do anything because they're already criminals. You know, someone that's a murderer
is going to use a weapon to murder because they're a murderer. Not because of the gun.
Law abiding gun owners take their responsibilities of gun safety very seriously. And 100%.
And, you know, the Second Amendment was written by our founders and is part of that sacred document.
And unfortunately, there's a lot of people in the state of New York that are in power that
have completely walked away from that. And, you know, the laws that they've written trample on
our Second Amendment rights. I have virtually co-sponsored every Second Amendment protection bill
that I've been offered here in Congress. I mean, I think we should have concealed carry
reciprocity across state lines. You know, if somebody, you know, has a valid, you know,
concealed carry, they should be able to protect themselves, even when traveling into New York.
I mean, and that's something I think that we desperately need and people would be a lot more
secure. I mean, New York wants, you know, so many laws that we can't defend ourselves.
And you should have the right to defend your property yourself and your family.
And I wholeheartedly believe that. And that's why our founders put it in the Constitution.
I got to tell you, I am so glad that you guys involved me. I am definitely going to be following
your career. And you definitely got to vote here here forever.
Well, thank you very much for being with us, Robert. I really appreciate it very much.
And have a great night. Next, we're going to talk to Steve.
Hi, Grishman. I believe how are you? Thanks for taking my call, Congress. I appreciate it.
My pleasure. Where do you call from tonight, Steve?
Fortune Park. Okay. Great to have you with us.
Oh, thanks. Thanks. I was recently received a diagnosis of mild cognitive impairment. And that
was, you know, I don't have Alzheimer's, but it's, it's so early in the screening process that I
am benefiting from the early intervention and the blood tests and such. And I know that you
sponsored the ASAP Act, the Screening and Prevention Act for Alzheimer's. And I was
calling about that just to see what you thought it might take to get it.
Over the finish line. I'm very sorry for your diagnosis and you'll be in my prayers.
The, you know, this terrible disease Alzheimer's and we've worked very closely since I came to
Congress myself and my staff with the Alzheimer's Association. You know, they're incredible advocates
and it's usually surviving family members of people that have lost loved ones.
And, you know, they've, they've brought some very common sense bills forward that I've been
proud to sign on to. The way these will typically work is, you know, there's a lot of things.
Obviously, there's an election coming up in November. So, you know, Congress will come back
in what they call a lame duck session in October or November and December. And, you know, we try to
do bigger size year-end packages where bills like this would get packaged with other healthcare
related bills and try to create a package that has, you know, strong bipartisan support. So,
we can get it over the finish line and get it signed into law. You know, this, we, you know,
I'm very proud to fight for, you know, more funding for Alzheimer's research and, you know,
different bills that help caregivers of people suffering from Alzheimer's disease.
But, you know, probably the most likelihood of us getting this over the finish line is
towards the end of the issue where typically things get packaged together
before this Congress ends and a new one begins because then all the bills that are out there
restart and people have to reintroduce them. So, you know, my hope is we can get some action on
it by the end of the year. Well, I know you've already co-sponsored the act. I was just curious
if you'd be willing to speak to your colleagues maybe. I'm an advocate for the bill and, you know,
the entire agenda that the Alzheimer's Association has put forward. We have to, you know, move it
through committee. I will be talking to our committee chair. I'm on the Energy and Commerce
Committee. It's Committee of Jurisdiction. It has all health care and those, those issue areas
for the Alzheimer's Association. But we will be advocates to not only get this out of committee,
but get this across the floor by the end of the year. Well, it's really amazing. The more I learned
about the Alzheimer's, the more I'm just convinced that this is going to be one of the largest health
care impacts, you know, in terms of society out there, you know, barring none. I mean, diabetes
or health disease or, you know, some of the other more serious things. It's just incredible.
45 million people, I guess, are expected to have in the next 10 years. And I think it's great.
I meet with a lot of companies and many have some really incredible drugs in the pipeline
that are in trial that I think are going to have big impacts on people's lives.
And that's, we've got to pray for that. And I, you know, really wish you all the best,
you know, with your diagnosis as well, Steve.
Yeah, well, thanks. The early diagnosis was pivotal. And I'm hoping to spread the
faith and make it available to a lot more people. I appreciate your support.
Absolutely. Be well, my friend. Thank you for being with us. Next, we are going to go to Fred.
Hello. Hi, Fred. How are you?
Hi, question deals with the SAVE Act. Okay. It seems like it's being held up by
soon because of the filibuster, which is not even mentioned in the Constitution anywhere.
It's just you have to get 60 votes, I believe, in order to be able to move legislation in the
Senate. Like, what does this guy think? And he's a Republican.
The filibuster, I believe it's time for the filibuster to go. I mean, it's a tool of the
minority party to stop progress. We had a 45 day government shutdown because of a filibuster.
I mean, we had passed the government funding out of the house 10 times, probably. And every
time they'd call a vote, it would fall short of 60 and they wouldn't be able to move forward.
It is just a tool of obstruction and it's got to go. I don't understand why Leader Thune
doesn't understand that this is just standing in the way of progress for the country. You're allowing
the party with less senators to dictate the agenda. And that's the reason we have 500 bills
that haven't been considered in the Senate because the Senate is just slowing to an absolute crawl.
They haven't passed a single appropriations bill in the Senate this year. We've passed,
I believe, almost all of them. And they haven't even negotiated. I mean, there's truly nothing
coming out of the Senate. And it's really unfortunate that they've allowed this to happen.
The filibuster needs to be used to go. It's nowhere in the Constitution.
It's not in the Constitution. It's just a tradition of the Senate. And they certainly
march to their own drummer over there at the Senate. And it's a big, cozy country club.
Yes. It needs to be, I don't know, demonapalized or something.
A majority should rule in this country. And when you have the votes, the bill will pass.
And that's how you make laws. But instead, we have to have a magic number. I mean, the idea that
you could have, I don't know how many times 53 senators voted to reopen the government,
but it couldn't open. I mean, if a bill passes by one vote in the House, it passes.
So this is foolish. What one other thought? I mean, I don't know how I watch
C-SPAN every once in a while, and they do the vote counts. Is there any way to do vote counts
without knowing what other people voted? It seems like the votes change, and then people
watch it, and then you've got people hanging on to the end, and then voting, knowing what the
score is going to be. Watch a Senate vote. They come through there. We vote electronically.
And I have a card, and it goes in the machine. And then when you vote, your name is up in lights,
up on the board, and it says a Y, or an N, or a present, if you wouldn't pick a site for some
reason. And it's, you know, 15 minutes is the timeline. They don't have a time limit.
They just call the roll, and then sometimes it just goes on, and then someone will wander in
two hours later, and they still count the vote. It's a very different system. But, you know,
you can bet that there's, you know, wrangling behind the scenes if, you know, it's close.
But, you know, the filibuster would certainly get the let out in the Senate, and I think that's,
you know, it's just not a responsive enough body. It doesn't move fast. The only time they move
fast is if they're right up before a recess. One other thought on something totally different.
Data centers, I think we got to really investigate these things and know
what they can do and what they can't do, because China wouldn't have their surveillance society
if they didn't have all the data centers they have. So that's like a downside to having
these data centers is the accumulation of all of our information.
Absolutely. I mean, we shouldn't be rushing into anything in the state. You know, the governor's
done a one-year moratorium. Other states have done pauses on building. You know, my mindset is that
we need to have local decision-making at the table. I don't want Albany telling us that, you know,
because land is cheap and plentiful in the southern tier that we have to have all the data centers.
And, you know, when you know how that works, when Albany does best, that's how we end up with
farm fields full of solar panels. You know, they won't want them in the New York City suburbs,
but, you know, all you country people can take it all. Local control and local zoning needs to
be restored. They took it away from us on wind and solar and all the green energy projects,
and that's why you've seen those take off like wildfire, because local zoning officials have no
say on the conversation. They can't stop it. And, you know, it might not fit the character of
the community. They're, boom, if they've got their ducks in a row and the courts don't find
false, they can build those windmills, those solar panels. I don't want to see the same kind of policy
happen on data centers. Local sighting needs to be done by people with skin in the game locally,
not a governor, not a downstate powerful leader of the Assembly or the Senate.
It has to be done that way. But, you know, we also have to have security that there's not,
you know, Chinese technology in there that's going to undermine our country.
And we need to be educated on what exactly these things are capable of. I mean, the good and the bad.
Yeah, there's fountains of misinformation about this argument. The good news is no one's rushing
into anything. I mean, you know, my guess is a governor will be singing a completely different
song once we get through November. And they'll start cherry picking places that, you know,
and she'll just decide where they are not having local people make those decisions.
I mean, I trust a mayor, a supervisor, a county legislature to decide whether a project fits
the character, the community, the impact and the natural resources. Obviously, it's all got to
go through state environmental and federal environmental. But the sighting in the decision
on where it goes, I trust local people way more than I trust a governor or someone whose power
derives from New York City. I agree. Thank you. Well, thanks for being with us.
Here tonight. We've got we're going to get another call in here. Let's talk to Lee.
Hi, Lee. Hi, this is right on the heels of something you just talked about. Very good.
Thanks for being with us. Oh, have you? Okay. I was talking to a friend at the fair.
And I said, have they, I said, has anybody ever thought about harvesting the methane gas from
the manure pits on the industrial cow farm? He said, actually, indeed, I've seen one of them in
the district, an incredible one in Randolph, New York. And yeah, I mean, yes, sir, it's the
greenest energy you could ever imagine. I know. The cows create all this waste. I mean,
the farmer who has 7,000 had a cattle in all of his farms, but this particular site had 4,000.
And he had three different companies bid on his output, the manure. I have a friend.
Yeah, go ahead. It was a $20 million build out. The company was responsible for all of it.
And I asked the farmer, how long will it take to fill? And he said one month. That's how much
the cows produce. And that gas comes out, goes through a digestion process, gets put into
trucks and take into Pennsylvania where it's injected into pipelines and put out there for
people to eat their homes and power their houses. It's an incredible process. It's expensive to build
out. You know, I think you're going to see more and more of them. But they've got to have the scale
of thousands of cows to to feed an operation like that.
I know. I have a friend that is milking 4,000 cows.
Wow. And yeah, and he thought step ahead of everybody, like when they started to put in the
manure pits, as soon as he heard that was going to happen, he did it. And he's a young man. He's
in his 40s. So he's in the beginning of his life as a farmer. And there are farms out there
that are right in our community. I live in Bath, New York. And this is our port, New York.
So there are a lot of industrial farms out there. Is there any way you guys could look into that?
Absolutely. Happy to talk to any farmer. If you want to give us a phone call because I don't want
you to give your friend's contact information over this open line with thousands of people on it.
But if you could give the office a call tomorrow morning, and we would be happy to
have a discussion with you, we're taking down your number. Maybe we can just call you.
Yeah. What I will do, do you have an email address? I can find online, can't you?
Yes, for sure. But we're going to give you a ring tomorrow and maybe we could
handle it that way. Okay. But give me a little longer because I can talk to the,
well, you probably don't need to because you already know. So yeah, just go ahead and give me a call.
Absolutely. I look forward to it Lee. Thank you so much. I really appreciate you being with us.
Yeah. I'll try to look. I'll try to ask around and see if I know anybody else that's got large
amount of cows because that's what you need. There were companies bidding for the honor
of the of the cow manure. Oh my gosh. Well, I really appreciate you being with us tonight.
And we are in overtime, but we're going to take one more. I want to talk to Mary.
Mary, are you. I'm doing very well. Where are you calling from tonight?
I'm calling from East Aurora, New York. Well, it's great to have you with us. What's on your mind?
Okay. Well, as I explained, I might call for is
exactly question, but it's just a statement and why I will leave New York and we've already taken
the moves we are, you know, doing the unspeakable, which is going to Florida. And I'm really sad
about it. I lived in New York state my entire life. Let me tell you, I ain't that young soul.
We've lived here and I will stay to you in the following. I'll try to be short for you. Everything
that I hear these people saying is why we're getting the hell out of here. It's it's oppressive. And I
feel like I'm being controlled. I feel like I look over my shoulder. I have to find it. The PFC,
I have to get a license. I have to be controlled. And, you know, I'm just going to sum it up,
because all the people that were complaining to you, it's the same thing. But but a big thing
for me too is this. I'm retarded. We tried it for 10 years away. It was a previous federal employee.
I carried the insurance from them because they had a good deal with the
when you're left, you got the the the keeper rate, what do we call it? And I'm sitting here now
saying, okay, my health insurance premium now is more than one third of my my pension. Well,
it's more than one third of it. I just got a doctor's bill. My husband had to go somewhere.
He got a bill. Five hundred and ninety health insurance paid one hundred and forty six
dollars and seventy four cents. We had to pay an additional one hundred and twelve thirty six
and then more than three hundred and thirty. Health insurance is a packet.
And you know what? I live in Easter. I can drive down the street to class. And I look at that
stadium there with a mark of the stadium box. The giant beautiful name Highmark Blue Cross Blue
Shield. You can't pay my damn bill, but you can pay five point four five million dollars
to have your name set up there. And I'm thinking about it. All the people that were complaining,
you mentioned it, the increase in utility bills. I went along with that damn smart leader.
My elect. And I just feel like it's like, oh, and I don't know and I'm and I'm going to apologize
to you ahead of time because I didn't say that these things. So I don't know if it's really true,
but it infects me. Are you telling me really that you're driving the Amish out of the country?
I didn't deal with them all the time. We, we, we,
say people. Mary, could you go to a section of your house where you got a little better reception?
You're breaking up a bit. Yeah. Okay. I apologize. Let me go over here. Is this better? Am I better here?
I think you're a little better right now. Okay. Are you telling me that is honestly true?
Then we're driving the Amish out of here. You honestly tell me that it's true. I see
just the hope of a jeep on in the past, which is okay because I understand the respect.
But what about our people that have lived, I've lived this
70 years and I feel like in being taken advantage of. I feel like they're looking at me going on.
You don't like to get out because we have these people and oh, you're always out. You don't want
to get your vaccines to get out. And I feel like, I feel like I'm, I, by the way, talking once
before, and I told you this, I feel like I am an ATM for the government. You need more money?
Suck that to me. There you go. And, and I mean, and I, I, the other people all,
say talk about, you know, the controls and whatever things and really trip me off to have a good
conversation with you because I thought, oh my God, that's right. Oh my God, it's true too.
And I just feel like I don't know what's happening in this state. I don't, but I do feel, you know,
we're left it. We're looking at it as a nanny stick and whatever. And, and I, whatever. I know
that everything's different. You can see these differently wherever you go and I get it. But I
will also mention one last thing, which is looking at how things are going. We have actually
looked that are looking to leave the United States because I don't see. We're honestly,
I'm cared about as a citizen. The parties argue, the parties battle. They want to win.
But I'm sitting here paying 650 pounds a month for health insurance while they have their name
on the stadium, but you won't be my health bill. And I think that that needs all of it. I mean,
but on 14, it's all of it. Well, I will. Let me let me jump in here now, Mary, because I'm on
double overtime here with the, but thank you. I'll agree with everything you said right up until
you should leave the United States of America. I don't want to see you leave New York. I don't
want a single person to have to leave New York. And that's why I fight for what I fight for in
Washington to try to find federal solutions around really bad state policy. But our state has
become a vampire state. It's chasing people to the exits. I mean, our governor goes on television
and has the audacity to say, I know you went to Florida, but you should be patriotic and come back
to New York so you can pay for a lot of things for other people. I mean, she's lost the script.
She doesn't understand that people have left our state because they want more personal and
economic freedom period. Hard stop. They're second tired of a government that's too big
and doesn't serve the needs of the people. And again, I can't get overtly political and talk
about electioneering on this call, but everyone's got choices to make. And they have, she has walked
away from the values of Western New York. And we have long been held hostage by a hostile
government in Albany that's based out of a power base in New York City. But this is the
greatest country in the history of the world. Make no mistake, this is the finest country
in the world. And so you should never think about leaving the United States. I hope you don't have
to leave New York, but I certainly understand why people make that decision because they're
pushed that way, whether it's the government telling you that you have to build a house that's
fully electrified. They want to tell you what kind of car you're going to drive. They want to
micromanage everybody or child's education. There's a lot of very backwards decisions all while
increasing taxes, fees and regulations on people. These are the sad realities that we've faced
for many, many years in this state. And we do have to have people have to be heard. And I really
appreciate you being heard tonight. I certainly hear your sentiments loud and clear and I share them
that we need to have a better way forward. And we need people that understand we're driving away
our human capital in this state. We have got to wake up in reverse course in New York and
understand that those one-way moving trucks are a road to ruin. And we've seen a hollowing out
of populations. I mean, I have a conversation probably once a week with someone that says the
same thing that you just said to me. I got six more months in as soon as I get that pension,
I'm out of here. Me and my wife are leaving. The kids are already gone. I mean, those are sad,
stories. And, you know, we see towns that once had 5,000 people now have 2,000. And in some
stories, the numbers are even smaller on what's left behind. I appreciate you being with me here
to marry. I certainly share so much of your sentiment. And, you know, New Yorkers deserve
better. And people in western New York and the southern tier certainly deserve better.
Now, we have come to a close here. I want to thank you all for taking time tonight. I mean,
we had 6,000 people on the line tonight. I mean, this is an incredible forum. I'm so
appreciative of all of you, you know, welcoming us into your homes. We have a lot of big challenges
to tackle on behalf of the American people. And I'm honored to work towards solutions that are
going to help residents and families and businesses in western New York and the southern tier. Please
know that our door is always open. No problem is too big and no problem is too small.
If there's anything we can assist you with, if you've got problems with your social security,
your veteran's benefits, the IRS, you know, something simple, I get in a passport, call the
office, visit our website, Langworthy.house.gov. We're there to help you every day of the week.
And if I wasn't able to get to your question, you could stay on the line. We got through a
bunch of them, but there's still a few people left in the queue. You could leave a message and
we'll get back to you tomorrow. I really appreciate everyone. God bless you all. Have a wonderful
evening and God bless America.